Professor Charles Xavier mutant leader
loving caretaker genius teacher and
total absolute jerk and it's not just
that he does some pretty messed up stuff
sometimes occasionally professor X goes
full-on supervillain for all of Xavier
'he's talked about peace and love and
harmony is the most unscrupulous
hypocritical and manipulative of all the
x-men face it magneto was right
Professor X is downright dangerous
and nothing not even dead can stop it
easy eh you think that a man who runs a
school would have some respect for the
education system but you'd be wrong when
Professor X was just regular old Charles
Xavier
he totally scammed his way through high
school in the worst way you listen even
subtle in class Charles would read his
teachers Minds for answers and he became
the star quarterback by psychically
stealing plays from the opposing team
and did he show any remorse about
abusing his powers at home Charles
devoted an entire shelves to the
trophies he didn't really earn sonar he
only retired from athletic competition
because he got bored of how severely he
dominated all of the puny humans kind of
makes you feel not even too bad about
the whole leg zing
when Charles half brother Cain Marko saw
through the charade he went mad with
jealousy forcing Chuck to put him down
with the karate chop later Charles tried
to convince his students that Cain was
the true villain but here's all you need
to know after Charles's stepfather died
he kept the family's fortunes to himself
while Cain transformed into juggernaut
and worked as a hired gun we're not
saying that Charles is the bad guy here
but after all of the x-men are bedridden
because of juggernauts personal vendetta
against child that they had nothing to
do with he makes them sweep up the
mansion
certified jerk Murph
student body when Jean Grae showed up at
Alvin and Xavier school for gifted
youngsters she was noticed by pretty
much everyone except Iceman who had his
own reasons that weren't revealed for
about 50 years
angel beast and Cyclops all instantly
have the hots for Jean and when
Wolverine shows up it's more of the same
there's also the creepy bald mentor who
serves as both jeans teacher and
surrogate father figure and lusts after
Jean and secret for years after slapping
her in a skin-tight costume thankfully
aside from a single panel in x-men
number three in which Professor X
laments that the only thing keeping him
and Jean apart is his disability yeah
right the issue only comes up once more
but in a very big way in the 90s when
Professor X's darkest thoughts
manifested themselves as an alternate
personality called onslaught his crush
on Jean makes a surprising reappearance
making it clear that xavius have a thing
for Jean three years it's unsettling at
best and makes a lot of those early
x-men comics in which Jean is clearly
the professor's favorite student a whole
heck of a lot creepier control yourself
dude big fake-out Professor X used some
pretty interesting methods to train the
unruly mutant city school and when
throwing them into the life-threatening
danger room wasn't enough he wasn't
above using psychological abuse to keep
them in order
thanks you believed you were right
totally right in x-men number four
Xavier
loses his powers only to reveal an issue
later that surprise he was faking in
order to give the x-men a pop quiz in
x-men number 42 it gets even worse in a
battle with a creature called grotesque
the subhuman an explosion takes xavius
life and the x-men spend the next two
years mourning two years and yet in
x-men number 65 Xavier smugly rolls back
into their lives alive and perfectly
healthy because the guy who died wasn't
even Xavier in the first place
as it turns out he swapped places with a
shape-shifting human-caused changeling
who would
the world's most dangerous make-a-wish
kid changeling a former villain had been
diagnosed with terminal illness and
wanted to use his last few months on
earth to make a difference so professor
axe let him lead the x-men meanwhile
Xavier locked himself in a basement and
devised a plan to defeat an impending
alien invasion
when changeling fell during battle
Professor X decided to let them grieve
instead of letting them in on the gag
for two years
classic Charles giant sized jerk in
giant-size x-men number one Professor X
recruits a brand new group of x-men
including mainstays like Wolverine
Nightcrawler
storm and Colossus to rescue his
original band of mutants from krikawa
the living Island rebooting the
struggling x-men series in the process
however as the x-men learn in deadly
Genesis in the storyline basically
lifted from Futurama complete with a
bald old widow genius a heroes are
actually the feast one are you free by
any chance interested in becoming my new
spaceship crew lil crew or what happened
in the Old Crow that's not important
before Cyclops led the new group of
x-men to victory Xavier has deployed an
entirely different group of superheroes
to rescue his former students and then
erased everyone's memory of the team
when they all apparently died now
unfortunately for Xavier one of those
wins actually survived and called him
out Gabriel a mutant with the codename
Vulcan who also happened to be the
little brother of Cyclops and havoc
after the missions Agricola go south
Cyclops is understandably distraught by
Vulcan supposed death so Xavier deletes
all of the Scott's memories of his
brother in order to keep him calm that
doesn't work out so well when Vulcan
returns from space in his quest for
vengeance Vulcan kills a few minutes and
tell Cyclops in havoc the truth turning
them against Xavier together the x-men
star Vulcan but Cyclops vanishes and now
powerless Xavier from the x-mansion
honestly erasing your team leaders
memory of this awesome space bro because
you've gotten killed as a few moves
the Xavier protocols everyone knows that
when Batman created a series of plans to
kill his Justice League teammates it
didn't work out so well everyone knows
except for Professor X who did the exact
same thing yes
the surrogate father and mentor of the
x-men figured out in detail how to kill
each one of them which is revealed in
Excalibur number 100 after onslaught
takes over professor X's mind the x-men
visit more omec targets research lab to
retrieve the Xavier protocols which
explains how to murder every mutant on
the team need to get rid of Wolverine
simply sever his head and put it
somewhere else got a problem with cable
just amp up the tech no virus that
slowly consuming his body allowing the
disease to ravage his brain and body a
suit of anti cyanic armor will topple
Professor X himself now if you guess
that this story doesn't have a happy
ending well you know how comics work in
x-men number 65 a human Sentinel hybrid
named Bastian uses the Xavier protocols
to defeat the team in x-men number 84
Professor X's recent tracking computer
cerebro comes to life and uses the
protocols against the x-men when they
try to stop it from taking over humanity
in both cases the x-men prevail but not
for professor X's lack of trying
brain drain after Cyclops killed
Professor X at the end of Avengers vs.
x-men most people assumed xavius reign
of terror was over they were wrong in
uncanny Avengers number one the Red
Skull steals professor X's brain and
uses its psychic talents to try and wipe
out mutant kind of good it almost works
through using xavius powers the Red
Skull brainwashes the Scarlet Witch who
drove him to the brink of extinction in
half of them and tries to get her to do
it again next he incited Anton even more
in Manhattan and we need to late thaw
into turning against his teammates later
the Red Skull transforms himself into
red onslaught and uses Professor X's
powers to start world war hey and when
the Avengers in the
ax men tried to use this belt to bring
out xavius better nature they
inadvertedly turn all of the heroes into
villains and all the villains into
heroes kicking off marvel's epic axis
event that's Chuck for you dead for
years
Phillips no good thanks for watching
click the lubricant and subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know your loves
[Music]